I promise you I ain't worried about I'm
not one of them. I'm not worried about
>> probably. What you What you looking for?
>> Oh, and that's a roller, too.
>> What does the word be gotten mean?
>> To come forth from.
>> Huh? Proceed.
>> To come forth from. Is there anybody
else that wants to try it?
>> He actually engaged with us and had a
conversation. It was fine. But he
didn't. He was like, "Man, y'all not
about truth. I'm going to get y'all
kicked out of here." He called the cops
on us and left.
It's got It's
got the
It's got the
>> Okay.
>> All right.
>> Yeah.
>> Do the combo. He going to admit it.
>> All right. Let me put it on here cuz if
you blazing on me, bro.
>> If y'all pro If y'all If y'all blazing,
you know what I'm saying?
>> First of all, I need to know where you
got that jacket, man. That jacket is
hard.
>> Jacket, man. That jacket is hard, man. I
need I need a jacket like that, dude.
>> That jacket is tough.
>> You got the Jordans on, too.
>> Oh, he's proud of us.
>> Oh, man.
>> You ain't no ball.
>> I need that.
>> Here we go. All right.
>> You say prove to you that Issa is
Muslim, right? Yes. Actually,
there wasn't no consonant J in that
town. So, his name was Issa.
>> It wasn't Isa either.
>> No, no, no. It was Isa.
>> Yes.
>> But that ain't what you want me to
prove. He
>> He's first me prove is this.
>> What you wanted me to prove is Jesus was
Muslim. All right.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay.
>> I got one question.
>> Yeah. I ain't talking about that right
now. About some God drink.
>> All right. Here you go. Was
Jesus this a question anybody can answer
it. Was Jesus one who submitted to the
will of God?
>> Yes.
>> He was.
>> Okay.
>> Real simple. Do you agree that Jesus is
one who submitted to the will of God?
Whoever believe that raise their hand.
>> We all believe it.
>> We all believe that Jesus submitted to
the will of God. Right.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> What does Muslim mean?
>> One who submits their will to Muhammad
and Allah.
>> That's not the truth.
>> Oh. See, Muslim means one who submits to
the will of God.
>> Which which God Muslim out HERE
is one who submits to the will of God.
>> Yes, sir. That's right. Me out.
>> What can I We got to We got to talk
about it.
>> No, that's all we had to do.
>> You got one who submit.
>> No, this doesn't. No, it doesn't.
>> It literally just No, it doesn't.
>> You arguing about it. I just prove it.
>> Well, we we we got to we got to talk
about it. You got to
>> No, we got to we got to talk. We got to
talk.
>> You got to hear my kind of argument.
>> Come on. Come on. You just said it,
>> brother. Look, I am willing to I I'm
willing to get a money,
>> brother. I'm What you mean? HE JUST AND
HE JUST
>> BUT YOU GOT TO let me talk to you.
>> No. All right. Come on. Give me the
conversation.
>> Okay. Thank you, brother. Thank you. All
right.
>> Do we already went there? We all agree
first. They owe me 2022.
>> No, nobody agrees yet.
Not yet.
>> Not yet. Remember, you got to you got to
prove it. You stated your case. Now, we
got to see if it stands. All right.
Okay. So, you said that a Muslim is one
who submits their will to God. Yes.
>> Okay. So, if I say that I submit my will
to God, but the God I'm talking about is
a statute in my backyard. Am I a Muslim?
>> Well, no. Because see, in the Ten
Commandments,
>> it said, "Thou shall not commit
idolatry." I D O A L T Idol. All right.
Hold on. Right. I'm with you.
>> Now, idolatry is worshiping anything
that has a molecular structure. Sound,
right? Water, everything, right?
Anything that has a molecular structure
that's incompassed by 360 degrees of
direction.
>> Can I come in here? So, I'm I'm with
you, right? So, you cannot you cannot
worship an idol and say that you are a
Muslim, right? So being a Muslim is not
just submitting your will to God because
somebody can believe that their God is a
God, right? But you got to submit to
what Islam teaches God is. Correct.
>> What is Islam?
>> Well, that's I'm I'm surrendering to
Allah specifically.
>> Surrendering to the will of Allah. A
Muslim is one who surreners to the will
of Allah. Islam is submission or
surrender to the will of Allah.
>> I got you. So now if I say I submit my
will to a statute or anything like that,
that's not Allah, right?
>> No, sir. Allah not a statute.
>> We're good. So then there's a specific
concept of Allah that we have to have
and surrender to in order to be Muslim.
Is that right?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Okay. Good. So now what you need to
do is not just show me that Jesus
submitted his will to God. You have to
show me that he submitted his will to
Allah specifically.
>> To Allah specifically.
>> Yes sir.
>> What is Allah? This was an asked.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> By one of one of the companions, they
asked, "What is Allah? Who is Allah?"
And he answered the question. He say,
"Do they ask why is Allah?"
>> I'm about to explain it to you. He say,
nor is he begotten
>> and there's none comparison unto Allah.
>> That's right. I like that. Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. Now, check this one out.
>> All right.
>> When Isaam as he say Jesus was on Mount
Gali, how did he pray?
>> Not what?
>> How did he pray?
>> Wait, just really what mountain?
>> When Jesus as he say Jesus, I'm going
say Issa. Go ahead.
>> He was on Mount Gali.
>> Mount Gal. How did he pray?
>> How would you tell us?
>> No. Come on. Come on. You bringing it.
No. I know your All right. Let me touch
on this real quick. Okay. cuz I heard
you out right. So when you say you're
talking about specifically Allah, you
quoted a beautiful chapter. Chapter 112
sur
>> I know but but notice notice I asked you
one question brother and you went on the
whole thing as you question but notice
I'm not I'm answering your question bro
but you got to listen to me too.
>> Notice you got to listen to me but
you're not you're now over talking me
>> face down on the ground.
>> So now you don't you know now you don't
want the conversation bro the Bible say
right? Do you want the Do you want the
money or not?
>> That's what he said. I'm not
>> That's what he gives.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE ANSWERED THE MONEY.
>> I'M NOT SAYING you need it the money.
>> So then you're if you're going to give
the hawk, then you should be able to
have a conversation, brother. Okay. So,
let me talk to you too. Okay. So, I'm
just I'm responding to what you said and
with your answer. Okay. So, now you
about to wait up to me, too.
>> What we going to do? What
>> before we go any further?
>> What else we going to do
>> about this 22? I only talked to one
person at a time. Well, this $200 come
in hand, right? We going to have a vote.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Now, who all said that I
prove that Jesus was Muslim? That's fair
enough. Compared to who said that they
ain't?
>> That's fair. That's fair. That's fair.
2200. That's fair.
>> Right now. And with my 2200, I'mma give
it to the home.
>> All right. Okay. Cool. All right. Sam,
sounds good. Proceed to your question.
>> All right. Okay. So, so we now we have a
a a baseline of where you're getting
your idea of who God is, right? Meaning
you're getting it from the Quran. What
the Quran said, like what you just
quoted. You quoted suras chapter 112.
>> It said, "Who is God?" I'm coming from
the Bible. Because if that's what you
want in Mark 12 28, one of the
disciples, no 28 and 29.
>> 28, it wasn't a disciple to 29. When one
of the disciples heard Jesus reasoning,
well,
>> it wasn't a disciple, bro.
>> Yes, it was.
>> It was one of the religious leaders.
>> Everybody from I've been Muslim only 30
years. I used to be a Christian. I used
to be one. how you be.
>> But notice you're you're about to show
me a verse where Jesus says that there's
one God. Right?
>> Jesus said in the King James version of
the Bible
>> here, O Israel, the Lord our God, the
Lord is one.
>> No, you're starting it from here. We
going to start it from the beginning.
>> But you but you cut you cut it you you
cut into me when I was trying to explain
to you and talk to you, bro.
>> So if you're going to do that, then
there's no conversation to be had.
You're just going to over talk
>> of all command.
>> But he don't got the mic. I got the mic.
So it don't matter.
>> Hear Israel, the Lord our God. Who is
that?
>> Our God is one God. And which you love
him with all thy mind. Who is that? Thy
soul, thy understanding. The Lord our
meaning Jesus got a god too. He's not
God and he's not.
>> Who is that? Who is that? Who is that?
>> Who is it?
>> Who is who?
>> Who is that God? He said is one. Who is
that?
>> I already went through that when I
recited it from the
>> No, you didn't. Because see now you're
now you're mixing two things. You you
quote the Quran where it talks about
Allah is one. He doesn't begin nor is
his begotten. There's nothing like him
in creation. Right? This is who you
described Allah is to be in the Quran.
Now, what you need to do is is you need
to show me that when G the one God Jesus
believes in is the same God that you
just described in the Quran. Like for
example, it says he doesn't begin nor is
he begotten. Right.
>> Oh, I see what you Thank you. Hold on
then. I got you.
>> So, who does Jesus say his God is?
>> Let me let me help you out.
>> All right. Help me out, brother.
>> Allah. Uh-huh.
>> Hold on. Hear me. Let me
>> All right. Yeah, man. Get it out.
>> Get it out. Get it out.
>> All right.
>> Did you want to Did you want to go next?
>> No. Hold on. No. We going to stay on me
cuz I'm going to go for that. I'm going
to go I'm
>> All right. He go He He going for it.
Stay with me.
>> You stay with me.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Yeah. Focus up, Logic.
>> All right.
>> Stay focus.
>> Stay focused, Logic, cuz I lose you,
brother. Actually, I won't lose you, but
I inshallah I'm going to win you.
>> Hey, praise God. Inshallah.
>> Inshallah. I'm going to win.
>> And Sh Yes, we win you.
>> Okay. Cuz you know it's ironic cuz I was
just building with all the brothers on
seven mile grass. The Hebrew Israelites.
>> Oh, you was talking to the Hebrew
Israelites, man.
>> Brothers, brother. Them brothers know
what time it is.
>> They know what time they said on the
corner yesterday. And you know what they
said? They said, you know what?
>> According to the Torah,
>> I am Muslim. I said, yes, you are,
brother.
>> Ah, well, they were wrong.
>> Okay.
>> They were wrong. buddies, you know.
Praise God.
>> All right. All right.
>> Dre say he said yesterday.
>> Yeah. So, so remember guys, we're trying
to figure out if Jesus believed in the
same God that's described in the Quran.
>> All right. I'm going to show it to you.
>> Okay. Now, quoting the Quran is not
going to help me.
>> Huh? Hold on. I'm going I'm going to
quote two things
>> about who though.
>> What you about to see?
>> Okay.
>> Be patient. You got to be patient.
>> All right. Cool. I'm just trying to
figure out who did Jesus believe in.
>> Grasshopper.
>> Okay.
>> Who do you believe in? Matter of fact,
while I'm looking for that, I'mma throw
one something at you.
>> Throw something at me, man. Hey, I'm I'm
ready for it. Whatever. Whatever you
got, man.
>> When he was on the cross, allegedly,
>> he said, "What?" Eli, Eli, Lama
Sebastian.
>> What that mean?
>> My God. My God, why have you forsaken
me?
>> Yes, it does.
>> That's one word. El is not in there.
>> Yes, it is. The it's Aramaic. Brother,
the word the word is L and the I is the
possessive. It's no he didn't
say.
>> No, he didn't. Moses said and
say
they never said that. Brother and Eli
are two different words man.
does is accept.
>> Prove that, right?
>> Prove that and I'mma give you 20.
>> These are two different uh languages
you're talking about. One is Aramaic,
one is one is Arabic.
>> You going to double it?
>> Yeah, I'mma double that. I got that.
>> I believe you. I believe you.
>> Pull up, bro. I got 10,000 in the back
seat right now.
>> Don't say that too loud.
>> I ain't worried about it. I promise you
I ain't worried about I'm not one of
them. I'm not worried about
I'm not worthy.
I ain't no mother. I ain't hard, but I'm
a guy for what I believe in.
>> That's right. That's right. That's
right.
>> Okay, my dog. Let me give you this one.
Let me here it come. It's right here. I
ain't got my glasses on. That's why it's
taking me so long.
>> I can probably help. What you What you
looking for?
>> Oh, and that's a roll, TOO.
OH,
I like that 2200.
>> He don't need it, man. He going He going
to pass it away. He going to win the
money and just throw it up like,
>> "No, I ain't doing that." He ain't going
to give your money to no fools. I'mma
give it away to those who need.
>> That's right.
>> All right. We coming.
>> Hold on.
All right. Here it come. Right.
>> Which chapter you in?
>> Hold on. We coming.
>> You got We coming.
>> I can't. You're not going to let me
look.
>> Give it to you.
>> I just want to see what what where you
coming from.
>> From Ibaka.
>> Okay. Chapter two. Okay.
>> I'm coming from Ibaka.
>> All right. All right.
>> Okay. Chapter two, man.
>> All right. You ready for
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. I'mma give it to you in the Arabic
first.
>> No, not the Arabic, bro.
>> Do it how I want.
>> Can't none of Can't none of us
understand that.
>> I'm give it to you Arabic first, then
I'mma translate.
>> The Arabic don't help me.
>> It's going to help you.
>> How? I can't understand nothing. Yeah,
wait. No, no, no, no, no, no. Hold on.
Wait. Let me get it for you.
Did you say
okay in translation finally
>> Allah
>> there is no deity except the living
Allah
>> the ever living the sustainer of
existence
>> right
>> neither drowsiness overtakes Allah nor
sleep to Allah belongs whatever is in
the heavens and whatever is on the earth
who is it that can intercede with Allah
Except by Allah's permission. Allah
knows what is before them and what will
be after them. And they incompass not a
thing except with Allah's knowledge
except for what Allah wills. Allah's
cursy extends over the heavens and the
earth and their preservation him not.
And he is the most high, the most great.
>> I said, how did that help me?
>> Hold on. I'm about to ask you this.
>> Wait, but you supposed to that's
supposed to help me with what what I
asked I've been dealing with the
Christian for so long and with the
nation. Y'all like but not this type of
Christian.
>> I promise you, brother. I've been with
you.
>> You ain't never you ain't never met
nobody like me, man.
>> I'm telling you, I want to say I saw you
on land for mission.
I'm telling you. All right. Now,
there's only it say there is no deity
except him. No god except that one God.
>> Okay.
>> Jesus said that,
>> right?
>> How do you know he's talking about this
God?
>> I'm about to explain to you. You got to
be patient. grasshopper chilling.
>> All right, get get all help me, buddy.
You got to get to that part.
>> There's no deity. There is no God except
that one God. Mark 12:28 and 29.
>> Who is that God, brother? Who is
>> that? God is the everliving. Is God ever
living?
>> Wait, is that what Jesus said?
>> Hold on. Listen, brother. We going to go
through that.
>> Okay. That's That's what I'm asking.
Which one?
>> That's what I'm asking. Which one are
you talking about? The one in the Quran.
>> That's cool. I'm out this first
>> cuz you're not you're not you're not
giving me what I'm asking
>> cuz see I know how y'all deal y'all want
to play the sematics with the words and
keep on
>> No brother we no brother look it's like
if I ask it's like if I ask uh uh is is
God a father watch this is God watch
this is God a father is God a father
is God a father
>> I'm not asking you don't control me I'm
a
>> but just just respectfully Muslim Is God
a father?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, the Jesus that the God that
Jesus speaks about in Mark 12 is his
father.
>> Okay. Hold on. Let me
>> He's not TALKING ABOUT ALLAH.
>> THIS QUESTION about
>> It's over, brother. It's over.
>> John 3:16.
>> For God so loved the world because I
don't know your energy.
>> Oh, come on, man.
>> For God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten sonow
>> that whoever believes in him should not
perish but have everlasting life. Is
that the same God is in the Quran? Is
that Allah? Here's the question.
>> Anybody?
>> Hold on. Wait. Wait. You're smiling.
You're smiling.
>> Did anybody memorize the Quran?
>> What does the word begotten mean?
>> To come forth from.
>> Huh? Proceed.
>> Proceed.
>> That's what it means.
>> Yeah.
>> It means that Jesus came forth from the
father.
>> It means to proliferate sexually.
>> No, it doesn't.
>> Yes, it does, brother. You're tripping.
YOU BETTER PULL OUT YOUR DICTION.
>> That's one That's one definition. That's
not the absolute of the oldest of the
definition. That's one definition. In
order for you to go into the black
collag into the western dictionary, the
word begot, Moses and his wife begot.
Abraham and his wife be got that means
to pro.
>> That's one definition. That's not the
only definition, my brother.
>> Come on, man.
>> That's one definition. You're not wrong.
It's one definition, but you're but
you're negating the other definition.
That also just means to come forth.
>> Here you go. Here you go. So, look. If
if Jesus look hold on just really quick.
If Jesus says that God is our father,
just one second, brother. You got to
have a conversation.
>> All right. This guy don't want to talk,
man.
>> He don't want to talk.
>> If God is our If Jesus says that God is
our father, he's not talking about your
God, brother.
>> Allah doesn't beget. But Jesus says that
he's his begotten son. It's over. He's
not the same God.
>> All right. He goes something else for
you.
>> Something else.
>> He goes something else. Okay.
>> And somebody else want to try after
this. Go ahead. Last try.
>> Psalms 46.
Psalms 36.
>> What did it say?
>> Watch this.
>> William Shakespeare
>> cuz you quoting a lot of the Bible.
>> You know when Jesus didn't even bring
the Bible. Jesus brought the injil.
>> Then why is he why is he quoting the
Bible?
>> I know. He didn't. Jesus never quoted
the Bible
>> in Mark 12:29. He's quoting the Bible.
Sir,
>> it was called the Injil.
>> But what you quoted a verse where he
quotes the Bible?
>> The in the Bible. The Injil was not in
English, sir. How many languages you
speak?
>> How many languages the same amount of
language you speak?
>> I doubt it.
>> How many?
>> I doubt it. I speak more than one.
>> That's not the point. That's not the
point.
>> As I said to you, right, that
>> when I'm out to prove to you,
>> brother, you've been trying.
>> You I already done proved that.
>> No, you didn't. You didn't prove it.
Money in your pocket amongst who all
you.
>> But you got to you didn't prove
anything. stunt.
>> You didn't prove it.
>> I think you're stunt. So, back to what
it is.
>> All right.
>> King James was asked by William
Shakespeare.
>> We're not talking about King James or
William Lake Shakespeare.
>> King James,
>> brother. We're not We're not talking
about that, bro.
>> Old English language.
>> We're talking about whether or not the
God that Jesus preaches is the same God
of the Quran.
>> My name.
>> You haven't been able to prove it,
brother.
>> No.
>> Is there anybody else that wants to try
it? What are you trying to do? He trying
to get us kicked out now.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Let me let me go call the owner,
>> bro. Ain't no way.
>> Huh?
>> Come on, bro.
So you you
>> and may and may the Lord Jesus put it in
your heart, brother.
>> I've been there already.
>> May the Lord put it in your heart, man.
You never knew him.
>> I'm telling you,
>> you you never knew him. You got lost.
>> I know him better than you know your
own.
>> You deny him as the son of God. You
don't know him, bro.
>> I promise. I bet you you don't even know
what it what it means for him to be the
Messiah, brother. You don't even know
what that means.
>> The Messiah.
>> What does that mean?
>> Jesus going to come back and slay the
Antichrist, bro.
>> But what does that mean to be the
Messiah?
>> Jesus is the word of God, brother.
>> What does that mean?
>> You hear me? Jesus is the word.
>> Is the word of God created?
>> He going to come and slay the
Antichrist.
>> Brother, did you did you want to try?
>> We can't be Muslims if we don't believe.
>> We don't He failed at
>> that were like not complaining, but they
were saying that you all were like
bothering them. That's why we're here.
Yeah. The gentleman who tried to
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, no one came out of here
and complained about There was one There
was one dude uh who and he just left. He
was upset. We he actually engaged with
us and had a conversation. It was fine.
>> But he didn't he was like, "Man, y'all
not about truth. I'm going to get y'all
kicked out of here."
>> You know, he don't even own the place or
nothing like that. All right, guys. So,
we just had an awesome experience. A guy
attempted to give us some da da da
>> tried to give us some da. And what
happened was he tried to prove that
Jesus was a Muslim after getting
absolutely destroyed and embarrassed in
front of all the crowd he drew. He then
he then called the cops. He called the
cops on us and left. So he's been
watching us this whole time. Ended up
leaving once he saw the cops were here
and uh the cops just came and talked to
us. It was a good time. They said, "Oh
yeah, you're not bothering anybody. Just
keep doing what you're doing." Uh, but
it goes to show you this is it's
double-edged sword. You talk to us, you
get embarrassed. You don't talk to us,
you're cowards and you're running. But
you talk to us, you get embarrassed.
What you could do is you could call the
cops. You know, hopefully they take us
away or something. You know, let's try
to inconvenience them as much as we can.
And since we can't beat them
intellectually, that's da guys. That's
da.
It's God.